people say michelangelo didn't [ __ ] with
the church
they're like yeah he was not about he
was gay dude yeah he was not in you
didn't do the tour where they explained
the [ __ ] watch [ __ ] angels and demons
or whatever the [ __ ] you all [ __ ]
watch
don't make it all you love it
i don't know how you still didn't like
it but like this [ __ ] yeah
he's inside the brain or whatever the
brain yeah god is the brain so you did
do it i i mean everybody knows this
right what's the easter egg this is just
the [ __ ] like did little japanese
girls do that [ __ ] or whatever
so like michelangelo basically was
saying like oh god is you can interpret
a bunch of ways but basically god is
inside the brain of man yeah okay
you did
he didn't know that i'm educating him
okay i didn't i don't know what's unique
they make it look like a brain do you
see that oh okay so michelangelo is
painting he's painting in the crown
jewel of the catholic church being like
yo gosh is not even real
he didn't say it's not real well maybe
he did we don't that's what he might be
saying i understand now so you see the
picture where there it's not on the
ceiling it's on the uh
behind the altar or whatever like that
where uh
actually i forget which one it is but
the image where he's showing who goes to
hell who doesn't yeah michelangelo is
kind of lit outside of boyfriend he put
one of the popes in hell or some [ __ ]
nah he put the cardinals it's a pretty
big caveat outside of boyfriend
[ __ ] yo we and when we had stavros
here he really broke the time judge
people based on the time they were him
yeah 100 yeah because michelangelo we
got [ __ ] plazas dedicated to this
[ __ ] like it was what it was
but uh but he has this thing about who's
go it's like basically the rapture the
you can look at the image of the rapture
is this dante's inferno no it's called
the last judgment the last judgment yeah
and uh he's in it too which is kind of
fire
this is the little easter egg that's
kind of cool but there was one dude that
was talking wild [ __ ] about him and he
didn't like him right so he put him
being dragged to hell click on this and
drag and go
and zoom in and then look at the bottom
right it's the this guy the left no no
no but this isn't the picture yeah
you're that's zoomed in you got to go
like two images yeah okay yeah yeah now
yes take this and then zoom all the way
into the bottom right
okay now look at the bottom right that
guy on the bottom right that was his
biggest critic didn't want him to do and
was given mad push back about everything
he was doing he had he has him going to
hell and he has a snake wrapped around
him biting his dick off
and then another kind of cool thing is
[ __ ] animals that i could have yeah
they might was fetish
so
this thing right here
yeah
that's michelangelo
oh he's getting dragged into heaven or
some [ __ ] well his soul
exists in hell
whoa and his skin
they're trying to take him to heaven but
he knows the life that he lives no i'm a
bad guy yeah i'm saying wow but everyone
thinks i'm gonna be in heaven yeah well
that's fine i thought that's kind of
cool this is amazing but to me that
acknowledges that he is somewhat
religious yeah right he's he's going
he's not saying that that's him he's
just putting the skin suit in there so
he's like all right maybe i do believe
in this thing that's out here and i'm
going to be punished because i chose to
live this life
but in terms of like the imagery and
i've seen better paintings i i wasn't
blown away
he put god's ass randomly on the sistine
chapel oh also he was stealing mad
people [ __ ] like
he was walking around the vatican and
there's all these sculptures and like
all these faces and you can see who he
used the bodies and the faces to make
the images of god
so he's just walking around the vatican
be like that's a pretty good body i'll
just paint that as god's body i don't
like that face i'll paint that as god's
face
that's fire yeah maybe we all had ghost
riders but mid though
he still painted it you know what i mean
what the body looks like he's still
drinking himself what the [ __ ] he wanted
to do he painted as i'm saying he still
i don't fault him for getting
inspiration i don't know i was in there
i was i was i was one crazy thing about
this time is that like like right now if
you think about there's so many artists
that are probably nicer than him way
nice but we don't
like build them up or praise him to like
do some [ __ ] like that i'll say about
him specifically blown away by the
vatican dead say something specifically
i'm just saying mike about him and this
is important to understand like
he was also an engineer
and that's what's kind of crazy about
this type of helicopter bro that was
leonardo
but uh but this guy for example he
he's painting the ceiling right the
ceiling is very tall
he built
the rig
so he could paint the ceiling like he
constructed it he did all the
engineering to build it it doesn't seem
like that crazy but imagine your average
painter right now they don't know no
[ __ ] about [ __ ] but if if like hey
you're gonna get paid a bunch of money
to be able to get up there and paint
some [ __ ] they're gonna figure that [ __ ]
out you get paid a bunch of money it's
yo god wants you to come paint fam oh
this is 1500's no i'm not taking
anything away from i'm just saying we
don't appreciate art the way that they
did in the past but they also knew it
was marketing it's like people had
nothing to do like this is a movie we
also got tick-tock bro that's what
that's next
when you see these pieces like you
realize they're just like telling
stories and this is it's basically like
a movie before movie there's this column
in rome did you see that column it's
near the forum maybe it's basically the
story of the one column
it's like a really specific column and
it basically wraps around with a story
and for people that
just can't read they just understand
imagery it's the story i [ __ ] i
forget exactly what it is maybe of the
roman empire or how they conquered a
certain place whatever you could walk
around that [ __ ] for an hour and imagine
that like
that's your we watch the same friends
people go to bed watching friends but
imagine you took your kid and then you
explained what happened in each moment
that's a movie yeah so i i see
talks better bro i was i was i wasn't
with al but now i got with you
average tick-tock
right now so we got a bunch of these i'm
with you on that i i thought the sistine
chapel was mid i thought vatican was
kind of made there was advertisements
for mexico when i walked in there was
like four billboards from mexico and i'm
like i know they ain't advertising in
the [ __ ] vatican bro you got to
advertise heaven
[Music]
mexico
whole thing no advertising i also it was
my first trip to italy so i hadn't seen
any of the basilica in my first trip to
europe so i hadn't seen any basilica
[ __ ] i intended these churches that were
so beautiful right so the first thing i
saw was the vatican and i was like what
the [ __ ] this is incredible i haven't
seen anything like that it's good to
start there yeah and then you just go
into downtown and drive by wild [ __ ]
from thousands of years ago that's just
right in the middle of town yeah i mean
you could drive by the coliseum yeah i
know yeah you just walk by it getting
somewhere else my thing to you is that
you're blown away by this because you
went there
for a limited period of time if you live
there
you'll be over he always says it's to
stay in new york son you'll you'll be
over you'll be over it i don't want to
move to italy but people come from
around the world to see times where
they're blown the [ __ ] away don't know
that and we're so over it no i think
what we've made is incredible and i
think they're like
bro you you take a flight and you land
at jfk or you land in newark and you
look out the window and you get to see
manhattan the island is amazing that is
miracle absolutely impressive it's a
miracle what happened here so
and we're inside it so it's hard to get
perspective but like your building is
super tall you probably have views of
the city or something like that right so
it's like
you get to see what we did like and i
imagine you're coming from another place
you go to europe they don't got
buildings more than six stories that's
what they're fascinated by yeah they got
skyscrapers there it's it's it's
remarkable what we got there's no
question
it's also remarkable what they got but
when you look at like the history in the
history of like the empire for me what's
so fascinating is just to kind of like
live within the history to know that
there are people that just built these
things you're in the coliseum you're
like yo thousands of years ago
they got animals from africa
stealing babies bro that's crazy and
they had ships isn't that the craziest
one that's wild the fact they had whole
boats doing battleships in there yeah
and the coliseum wasn't even a big [ __ ]
the coliseum was little compared to what
they had in the forum that's the other
thing as well a crazy thing the dude
that i think it was nero that had the uh
the coliseum built i'm pretty sure it
was him
dude went crazy yeah and uh i think he's
the guy they traced off like the fall of
rome back to i think is that right i
think it's something you're a fiddler
uh yeah incest right there right no
lead pipes
oh yes they don't know that for a fact
but
he didn't get crazy until he was already
living in the royal facility
and
before that you're getting water from
whatever source you're getting from
maybe you have a well by your home or a
state it's not like he was poor but once
you're using the actual plumbing the
average person isn't getting access to
that just pulling right to the house
only the royals are so this dude is
getting that this is the one theory
getting that lead pipe water yeah man
went crazy
kills
peter
yeah
lead pipes made catholicism let's go
i'll just say like think about it right
like
yeah no there's no vatican without lead
pipes bro wow there's no vatican without
lead pipes you know what yeah
that's it that's a good ass point
honestly you got a good point i'm just
saying bro
ain't no vatican without left